welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Walking Dead season 11 episode 22. we
begin with our captured crew who's been
working on the railroad all the live
long day but they're plotting an escape
counting the guards and mapping out
their routes negan's got the paper where
he's writing it down but he starts in
trouble trying to get a break for his
pregnant wife ends up getting beat down
after this he's brought in to see the
warden because yeah they found the paper
it fell out of his pocket negan's like
yo man I don't know what that is but
it's like hey we know you're up to
something or one of your group is up to
something if you rat out the leader you
can get some perks like visitation time
with your wife now this work Camp is
actually based out of Alexandria which
the Commonwealth has fully taken over
but Daryl and Carol and the rest of our
crew are here plotting a rescue mission
it's like yeah we're way outnumbered but
Alexandria is our home we know it uh
we're gonna sneak in through the sewers
meanwhile Aaron and the road trip crew
are still on their way to Oceanside but
they run into someone from Oceanside
it's Luke yeah he's still on the show
and he gives him the bad news that
oceanside's been taken over by the
Commonwealth he and his girlfriend
weren't caught because they were away
and it sounds like he left before he
found out if Lance Hornsby did in fact
Massacre everyone but it's like Yeah The
Commonwealth is still still occupying it
and they're hunting us down which is
news to Aaron because when they left the
Commonwealth they had worked out the
deal with Pamela Milton that she was
going to let them all go and live in
peace but that was before her son died
and Commonwealth soldiers are coming
right now our group's got a hive so
Lydia's like well it's Whisperer time
again yes our group covers themselves in
zombie guts and walks with the herd to
uh you know avoid detection but remember
this is the group that's dealing with
potentially smart zombies and when one
of them drops their knife another zombie
falls behind him and picks it up and
watch out for that the other big plot
this episode is Eugene's trial for the
murder of Sebastian Milton being
defended by his master attorney yumiko
now I don't have a lot of agree but to
me it seems the obvious defense is that
all Eugene did was play the recorded
tape he didn't let in the zombies that
then caused the chaos and murdered
people including Sebastian so yeah I
would maybe bring that up and get him
acquitted immediately but um uh they
don't instead their defense is basically
to try to expose Pamela Milton as
corrupt to get the people on their side
because the judges obviously paid off
it's a sham trial but getting the people
on their side won't matter if the
Stormtroopers are still on Pamela
Milton's side so the key to saving
Eugene and bringing Pamela Milton down
is once again Mercer this time yumiko
goes in to talk to him like come on man
you know she's bad it's time for you to
stand up for what's right your
girlfriend princess was disappeared off
to a labor camp like you can't be okay
with that but Mercer is still not ready
to hear it he's like look the
Commonwealth ain't perfect but it's what
we got I gotta uphold lawn order and so
the trial is trying to a close and it's
very clear Eugene's gonna lose and so he
makes a final speech about doing what's
right and it's really cool because it
goes back to when he was with Negan and
the saviors he's like you know I wasn't
swinging the bat but I knew what was
going on that group was doing some awful
evil stuff and so being part of it I was
still complicit but now at the railroad
Ezekiel and Negan kind of have an
argument ezekiel's like yeah man I
absolutely don't forgive you for when
you were Super Evil and negan's like
fine man screw you so he goes to see the
warden and it looks like he's gonna give
Ezekiel up so that night all the
prisoners are dragged out of bed for a
big public execution but it was a fake
out Negan didn't give up Ezekiel he gave
up himself took full credit for the
Escape Plan yes Negan ready to sacrifice
himself to get suspicion off the rest of
the group and get better conditions I
think for his pregnant wife but the
warden pulls a sneaky on him and brings
his wife out out to be executed with him
it's like what this wasn't our deal but
the warden's just like a real bad dude
so now as they're about to be executed
King Ezekiel makes the choice to step on
up there in front of him and the rest of
our group comes up too like hey you're
gonna have to execute all of us the
warden's like yeah man I mean that's
fine do it but now this makes the guards
reconsider especially this one who we
saw the warden with super mean to so he
stands up goes for the ward and oh
what's this the warden takes a hostage
to escape but oh stabbed in the back by
Daryl who was lurking in the shadows
waiting for the right moment and so our
crew has liberated Alexandria but
remember the one thing that they all
care most about is their children but
the kids aren't all in the same place
Maggie rescued Herschel but they never
found Rosita's daughter Coco she grabs
one of the Stormtroopers who's turned
into a zombie like where's my daughter
but he's not saying he's just like screw
you so oh she lets him go and it eats
his face off in the final scene Eugene
is brought down to be executed in fact
he's brought to Mercer actually he
dropped one of the rare Walking Dead
f-bombs but basically he says I'm in
it's Revolution time so yes Mercer is
finally on board we're gonna start off
the Commonwealth Revolution and now
there's only two episodes left how will
it all end find out next time on The
Walking Dead
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]